[Gelächter]
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
eigentlich wollte ich gerade in meinem
Glitzerkleid hier stehen und die Super
Bowl Show eröffnen denn der Super Bowl
steht bevor und ich weiß dass viele von
euch ihnen anschauen werden nachts und
ich bin mal gespannt drauf wer die
halftime-show machen wird und werde die
Eröffnung machen wird ich bin ja Fan
gewesen von der Lady Gaga Show Shakira
and Jello das fand ich ja schon normal
richtig super und damit eure super
bowl-show kann das sein es geht beim
Super Bowl ums Football und ich
interessiert die Halbzeit so kann es
wirklich ernst ja echt jetzt
egal wer da spielt und wer gewinnt und
es geht schon ja also eigentlich ist mir
sogar egal wer gewinnt wer spielt ich
verstehe die Regeln nicht also sogar
nicht gebacken wir sind am Anfang des
Videos aber okay jedenfalls ist mir
wirklich egal denn eigentlich bin ich eh
nur für die Party zuständig ich bin nur
zum da für Unterhaltung Sorge ich
deswegen ist mir immer wichtiger wer
Auftritt was sie anhaben was sie singen
und wie cool die Show ist der Sport
interessiert mich gar nicht okay dann
ist halt so dann weiß ich dass ich das
Ding alleine anschauen werde und ohne
dich definitiv deswegen habe ich auch
schon was gebacken und zwar gibt es
heute ein tolles Gericht für eure Super
Bowl Party ich habe jetzt hier nämlich
kleine Brötchen die aussehen wie kleine
Footballs und falls ihr was fleischiges
machen wollt wie es immer haben will
dann schaut gerne auf meinem Kanal
vorbei ich verstehe
er möchte die Chicken Wings Platte er
will die hotdoggen Klasse er möchte die
große ja ja ja
und Burger und Hotdogs und ja manchmal
sagt der Körper was anderes und so sie
wurden ins Gesicht schmieren kann und
die Arme rein ja das ganze Gesicht so so
und dann genau so ja es ist
so das gibt es auch auf meinem Kanal
klickt euch einfach durch Würstchen
reinlegen können
ja
der einzige der noch Football
gemacht die schon richtig die
Halbzeitshow
das sind Männer mit Testosteron die
gegen die gegeneinander laufen ihren
Köpfen so warm oder macht Klatsch und es
gibt nur wenn man Würstchen
okay ich zeig euch mal die Zutaten für
den Teig denn diese Brötchen bekommt ihr
ganz schnell hin ist keine Hefeteig
sondern ein blitzteig Ja und macht noch
ein paar Würstchen dazu ein paar Burger
rein ja für den Teig verwende ich 700 g
Mehl ich habe jetzt hier einen
Dinkelmehl 630 einen Teelöffel Salz und
Päckchen Backpulver das sind drei
Teelöffel 200 g Milch 100 g
Sonnenblumenöl zwei Eier und 100 g
weiche Butter das hier ist ein
All-in-One Teig das bedeutet ihr könnt
einfach alle Zutaten in die Rührschüssel
geben und schön durchkneten lassen und
weil der Teig mit Backpulver statt Hefe
ist ist es wirklich auch ein blitzteig
denn der Teig wird sofort
weiterverarbeitet
also hier erstmal alles rein bei Mehl
gucke ich trotzdem immer dass ich
erstmal ein Teil nur mit rein gebe denn
manchmal kommt so ein bisschen auch auf
die Größe der Eier an die man dazu gibt
ob man etwas mehr oder weniger Mehl
braucht
[Musik]
und zwar ganz dicke Eier hat macht
gleich alle Zutaten
ja perfekt wenn der Teig dann nicht mehr
klebt ist das super also ich habe jetzt
auch ein bisschen weniger Mehl gebraucht
und jetzt kann ich den zur Seite stellen
und schon mal die Füllung vorbereiten
für die Füllung verwende ich 300 Gramm
Schafskäse und 50 Gramm Pesto ihr könnt
jetzt hier natürlich jede beliebige
Füllung nehmen die euch am besten
schmeckt ihr könnt auch Schafskäse mit
Petersilie mischen oder mit Kräutern mit
Gewürzen so wie Ihr möchtet aber wir
hatten jetzt gerade noch Pesto da
deswegen dachte ich pestool ist
eigentlich ganz gut Oliven passen auch
gut rein getrocknet Tomaten
Hackfleischfüllung alles mögliche nicht
zerbrösel den jetzt hier einfach mit den
Fingern und rühre das Pesto ein und dann
ist die Füllung auch schon fertig
irgendwie kann ich es gerade noch nicht
so glauben aber ja wir füllen jetzt
schon die Teigtaschen in dem jetzt ein
bisschen mehr dann den Teig
und meine 3 mm abstandsrollen
und dann rolle ich das hier schön dünn
aus
[Musik]
in seid ihr auch fleißig am Kochen und
Backen
und naschen und essen
ich auch
aber momentan bin ich auch gerade am
hart trainieren denn ich bin ja bei
Let's Dance dabei und ich komme nur
weiter wenn ihr für mich anruft das
heißt backt euch gerne was schönes aber
Freitag Abend da seid ihr bitte live
dabei bei RTL und ruft für mich an
ich will auf jeden Fall weiterkommen
jetzt ist der Teig schön gleichmäßig 3
mm dick ausgerollt
sind
ich weiß selber noch nicht wie es
aussehen soll doch ich weiß wie es
aussehen soll ich weiß noch nicht wie
ich ans Ziel komme aber das werde ich
jetzt gleich für euch herausfinden ich
nehme jetzt einen großen Ausstecher
einen runden
probier mal das jetzt mal hier
dann noch einen Kreis
es wird schon dann nehme ich den
mittleren Eisportionierer
und die Füllung
und die platziere ich jetzt schon mal
nicht in den kleinen Aspiration
denn der Ausstecher hat
ungefähr
[Musik]
bis 10 cm groß also kleiner
Eisportionierer
Füllung in die Mitte und die so ein
bisschen länglich anordnen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich alles das könnt ihr hier
den Rand so ein bisschen mit Wasser
befeuchten damit der Teig klebt dann
kommt der zweite oben drauf
jetzt habe ich mir zumindest vorgestellt
das ist damit noch mal so Football mäßig
nachsteche denn wenn ihr euch fragt was
ich nicht in meiner Küche habe dann ist
es ein Football Ausstecher und dann
nehme ich eine Teigkarte oder ihr könnt
auch eine Gabel nehmen und so ein
bisschen den Rand reindrücken dann hält
alles gut zusammen wenn es dann so ein
bisschen außer Form geraten ist stecht
ihr das einfach mit dem Ausstecher nach
und damit auch wirklich aussieht wie ein
Football kommt hier oben ein Schlitz
rein
und dann so quer noch mal einschneiden
[Musik]
ihr bestreicht jetzt hier eure Footballs
die footbälle
[Musik]
Plural mit etwas Ei und dann können Sie
direkt gebacken werden ihr könnt jetzt
einfach bei Heißluft Backen mehrere
Bleche gleichzeitig oder halt schon mal
eins backen und das andere danach denn
ich brauche noch ein bisschen Zeit für
das zweite Blech die sind jetzt schon
gut aus richtig gut
jetzt sind die Brötchen fertig
eigentlich hat er ja schon eins probiert
du darfst du nicht essen ich habe es
noch nicht gebacken du hast doch schon
zum Video gehört anfangsschluss
Hauptteil wie in der Schule
so okay dann probier halt noch mal ja
was habe ich vorhin gesagt du magst
lieber mit Fleisch und magst nichts mit
Käse so und jetzt ich esse welche ich
liebe das soll ich sagen
ich mag Käsebrötchen am besten Äste die
ganz warm und ganz frisch denn dann sind
sie wirklich am besten und der Murat
geht sich jetzt paar würstelgrille weil
er kriegt jetzt keins mehr von mir meine
Kumpels kommen ich mache jetzt ich Grill
mit dem jetzt ja ich habe da noch im
Kühlschrank
ja so und für alle anderen die
Käsebrötchen wollen das Rezept findet
ihr in meiner App in Sallys Welt App
oder auf Sallys blog.de
es ist Super Bowl
kannst machen ich schneiden macht's gut
macht es besser euer Murat ciao
[Gelächter]
[Musik]